and she's back good to see you
hey I like what you've done oh no I
wouldn't go in there if I were you
why not he got clearance to start
working from home after you left
Oh God why didn't you do something are
you nuts
I'm not going to touch him hey you good
luck hey so how was middle-earth
epic how are you wait what was the last
time you packed we should start at the
top had a haircut I have determined
really why should we spend 30 bucks
every few we can you know for that same
money I could get six buy-ins at the
magic gathering tournament down at Dark
Tower gaming or do they get better if
you get 3 to 6 second hand games
delivered from Amazon don't happen yeah
I can see that you know you don't give
Dave any crap about his hair I would
steal Dave's here if I had half the
chance yours gets molester eager are you
playing that scene to tell logic to
deodorant - I have not gone to the store
in all of wine and now you may never get
there see you've congealed into the sofa
you know there are places on this planet
where they would boggle my Muskaan's so
why don't you go
do you want in on this I think it might
be better to play from a distance online
no would be if your little jaunt around
the islands hadn't wiped you out
financially and left you incapable of
buying your own copy chain maille I'm
out of shirts wins